JEREMY WALKER: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have a pretty exciting
show today.
But before we get started, I
want to introduce myself.
I'm Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer advocate
for the YouTube APIs.
Then we have Jeff Posnick
visiting from New York.
He's my counterpart
out in New York.
I think he's on mute.
JEFF POSNICK: Hello
to everybody.
Hopefully, you can hear me.
JEREMY WALKER: Yep.
JEFF POSNICK: And thanks for
being on the show, to the
folks that you're about to
introduce from WeVideo.
I'm looking forward to it.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
So we're really excited to have
some of our partners here
from WeVideo.
We have Krishna Menon,
who's the CTO.
And then we have
Mark Floisand.
MARK FLOISAND: That's right.
JEREMY WALKER: I always worry
I pronounce that wrong--
who's from business
development.
So we're really excited.
We've been partnering with you
guys for quite a while.
We worked with you guys at I/O.
And we've done some other
recordings.
But we haven't had you
on the show yet.
So we're really excited to
finally get you here.
MARK FLOISAND: And we appreciate
being here.
Thank you.
KRISHNA MENON: Thank you.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, let's jump into it.
We want to cover a couple
general questions first.
And then we have a demo for
everyone out there.
So that'll be pretty exciting.
And then we'll get into
the technical details.
So why don't you tell me a
little bit about the history
of WeVideo.
MARK FLOISAND: So WeVideo
was founded last year.
And we're based up
in Palo Alto.
We're practically neighbors.
The company actually is based
on a platform of technology
that was originally conceived
in Scandinavia
about five years ago.
And that technology platform was
originally very much aimed
at schools.
So we had about 400,000 school
kids hammering away at this
cloud-based video and
collaboration environment.
And WeVideo was conceived to
take that fundamental concept
and that code and really,
frankly, democratize video--
to enable us to reach many,
many more people globally.
The company was founded over
here in Silicon Valley.
We received a round of funding
earlier this year and have
been growing since.
So we're really focused on
trying to just make video
editing much easier to do and
available for everyone.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So democratizing
video editing.
MARK FLOISAND: Yeah.
You think of, obviously, the
huge reach that YouTube has
with regard to video viewing.
Everyone that's online has
now seen video online.
And as a media category, it's
obviously growing like crazy.
What's lagged behind that is
people's ability to actually
edit their own video.
And so what we see is this huge
demand for people who've
captured a lot of video, who are
used to sharing and seeing
video, but are perhaps
frustrated by how difficult
it's been in the past to edit
that video and make it really
compelling.
And so we think that there is
a great opportunity to make
editing a key part of the value
chain, if you like, and
make it easy for people to edit
their work, then share
it, which makes it much more
compelling, much more
interesting for people to
view, and overall drives
better content.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
And to be clear for everyone out
there, it's not like you
need plug-ins or anything
like that.
You can just go to your site
and start using it as if
you're using an installed
view editing suite.
MARK FLOISAND: That's absolutely
true, Jeremy.
As a cloud-based video
platform, one of the
advantages we bring is that
people don't need bespoke
downloadable software.
And a key part of, I think,
frankly, our success together
and working with yourselves
has been we were able to
effectively embed that
capability into YouTube itself
or into one of the properties
that enables people to
actually work on editing our
files from within the YouTube
creator program.
So what that's done is I think
it's made it very accessible--
the editing component of it--
and really helped people to
improve the quality of their
content without needing
downloadable tools, complex
software editing, and so on.
And some of the things that
we'll show everybody today are
how we've evolved from that.
Because I think when we started,
we had a relatively
sophisticated platform.
And what we found, certainly,
in talking to our customers
was it's still hard.
So someone who's never
done any video
editing, it's still hard.
And so we've made it easier.
We've continued to strip away
at the editing process, to
narrow down to the core essence
of what people need to
do to produce great content and
to be able to tell their
stories easily.
And that's what's
embedded in our
implementation with YouTube.
JEREMY WALKER: Well, I'm
always excited to--
it's really neat to hear about
it, but I always like to see
it in action.
And I know you guys have a new
list of features that you
launched recently that I'm
hoping you'll talk about.
So why don't we--
Krishna, if you want to jump
into the demo, and then you
can talk about the
new features.
And then we can talk about
the technical stuff.
KRISHNA MENON: All right.
I'll walk you through the demo,
but I just wanted to
emphasize something that Mark
said, which is what we learned
was that a number of users who
came to our site had actually
no video experience.
So they had to do
a video project.
They had content.
But they didn't understand what
video editing was about.
In response to that is
what we came up with.
And what I'm going to
show you today is
our most recent offering.
We just launched it
a few weeks ago.
It's a storyboard version.
So it's intended for
novice users.
It's intended to still create
great quality videos.
So even though the user
experience is simplified, we
still want to give them
the ability to
create great videos.
And a term I'm going to talk a
little bit about today is what
we call adaptive user
experience.
So while you can start off
with this, we also have
versions for you that, as you
graduate and as you become
better at it and you want more
control over your final
output, we have more advanced
versions for
you to start using.
And the data between all the
versions is going to change a
little And I'll show you that
as I do the demo today.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So it's like an easy version
to start, and as you get
better, you throw more stuff
in there for them to
use to refine it.
KRISHNA MENON: That's exactly
what I [? meant. ?]
But all the data's
interchangeable.
So you can take the data from
one version to another without
any loss of fidelity.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
KRISHNA MENON: All right.
So what you're seeing on my
screen right now is our
storyboard version.
So this is the latest editor.
On the left hand side
is all my content.
So assume I just came back from
a skiing trip and I've
got some content.
And at the bottom of the screen
is the storyboard.
So that's where, actually, I'm
going to put together my
storyboard from this location
I just took.
Now, the way we bring content
into the system is either I
can upload from my hard disk, or
you can also bring it from
all these different sources.
So obviously, Google Drive
is a big part of ours--
Instagram, Facebook.
So you don't have to download it
from those sites, bring it
to your desktop,
and upload it.
We can directly connect to those
sites to bring it your
content [? within. ?]
So I'm going to put together
a simple storyboard.
I'll go through it.
So I'll go through and
pick a few clips.
So I'll drag this one in here.
And I'll pick a couple more.
And then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to do some
editing to make it better.
And I'll pick another
one here.
So what this also allows me to
do is I can easily drag and
drop, move things around.
So as I reorder things
in my storyboard,
I can move it around.
I'll just pick one more clip
here to finish it.
So now I've got a little
storyboard that I've put
together in a few seconds--
nothing sophisticated.
I've got a little title slide
and I've got a few clips.
And I can play--
it's still not edited.
I haven't done anything
with effects.
I don't even know what
effects are.
Now, some of the concepts are
available to everybody.
So if I wanted to just
give it a title, I'll
call it Skiing 2012.
And then, also, on
the different
clips, I can add titles.
So I can put a caption that
says, Getting There.
And also, I could
tag a friend.
So the tagging a friend-- again,
the idea here is that
if you tagged a friend and you
publish it, then we notify
your friends that you were
tagged in this video.
So there's a social element
to the editing, also.
And I'll just go ahead and add
a few more captions here.
Oops.
Again, the concepts I'm showing
you here are concepts
most users are used to.
And I'll add one more here.
So now, if I just play these,
you can start seeing--
I'll just go to the beginning
and show you
what it looks like.
So I've got the titles.
And now, what we get to is the
interesting part of it.
So now, I've put together a few
clips and I've got some
titles and captions.
And we have a concept called
Styles and Themes.
So the idea here is that we
want to give you create
quality video without you
understanding what
it takes to do that.
So if you don't understand
effects, if you don't
understand audio, if you don't
understand transitions, we've
done that for you.
So I'll pick a theme here.
I'll pick the vintage theme,
use it, and let
me just play that.
At this point, what it's doing
is it's downloading the
resources for that theme.
Now, for us, everything
is real time preview.
So you want to be able to make
changes and see it right away.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, cool.
KRISHNA MENON: So it's doing
the transitions.
It's done some color
correction.
It's added audio to it.
And basically, [? I ?]
[? say, ?]
[? you know what, ?]
I don't mind that.
Let me try a different one here
and I'll just go ahead
and try my 1960s theme.
[CHUCKLING]
MARK FLOISAND: Shows
your age, Krishna.
KRISHNA MENON: Yes, and I'm
dating myself here.
So again, instantaneous--
an important thing in creating
is you want quick iterations.
You don't have to
wait and render.
So I can see something
right away.
And we have that we have 20 plus
teams right now that you
can go and try out with it.
And then the final step is, once
I'm done with that, I can
go ahead and publish it.
And this is where the YouTube
integration comes in.
So I can set the resolution.
I can mark it as private.
And I can just go ahead
and publish it now.
So what this is going to do is
where we do the integration
with the YouTube APIs.
And the first part of this
is that we'll take your
storyboard.
And it's all server-side
processing.
So we've got a rendering farm
on the server and a
cloud-based infrastructure
that's going to take that
content, take the high
resolution versions of it,
render all the effects, and
create a single output file
out it, high quality, and then
we take that file and publish
to the YouTube channel
for that person.
So that's the process.
So what you've seen here is,
basically, in a few minutes,
I've put together a good
quality video.
JEREMY WALKER: Wow,
that's neat.
And so this is for the
beginners, and
then, as they start--
well, actually--
KRISHNA MENON: So let
me just show you.
So I've done this now
and I want to say,
OK, you know what?
I actually want to go ahead,
I want to do a
little bit more editing.
I'm actually not a novice.
So I can now switch over
to the timeline mode.
So this is the next level
of the editing.
Notice now, the look
is different.
It's not as-- the storyboard
version.
It's showing me a lot more
elements of the timeline,
including what effects
are applied and the
audios and all that.
So if I wanted to now go ahead
and add a voice over or change
the effect-- and if I said, you
know what, I actually like
this theme, but I want to use
a different effect, I can do
that here easily without losing
all my previous work.
So again the idea of adapting
the user experience--
that's our philosophy in
developing applications.
JEREMY WALKER: Wow, that's
really neat.
OK.
So even if you are experienced
but you have a limited amount
of time, you can just pick a
theme, throw together your
clips, and then you just
export to YouTube.
KRISHNA MENON: That's
exactly right.
And for us, it's not only having
versions for different
levels of users.
Our vision is to have this
running on all devices so it's
basically web platforms,
tablets, smartphones.
And those are coming
in the future.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
So you guys have something
planned for mobile, then?
KRISHNA MENON: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
That's good to hear.
MARK FLOISAND: Especially
for Android.
JEREMY WALKER: Android.
[LAUGHING]
JEREMY WALKER: That's what
we like to hear.
Well, why don't we dive into
the technical side?
So do you want to talk a little
bit about how the
integration went about, at least
with YouTube APIs and
then maybe what language
you used?
KRISHNA MENON: All right.
So we used Version
2 of the APIs.
Version 3 came out recently.
And we're going to look into
that starting in January.
As I mentioned, for us, the
integration was about once we
do the rendering in the cloud,
we take that file and we use
the YouTube upload API.
So it's basically the data
APIs we're using.
We're not embedding the
YouTube player.
We're using the data API
to push the file up.
Our back end is all written in
Java, so we used the Java
client libraries for the data
API to integrate the upload.
Besides the upload, we also
do check the status.
We add developer tags so we
can search for WeVideo.
We want to get the URL back
and email it to the user.
And we're also looking to
tie into analytics.
So we want to give the user
information on how many views
did their creation get?
And then eventually tie it to
things like gamification--
create a video that gets
10,000 views or
something like that.
So that's the level of
integration we've done.
The integration itself was
very straightforward--
no issues at all.
And we're looking forward
to what the
Version 3.0 has to provide.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
Oh, go ahead.
JEFF POSNICK: Sorry.
You mentioned analytics.
Have you had a chance to look at
our new standalone YouTube
analytics API also?
KRISHNA MENON: We've started
looking into it, but the idea
there is that the information we
want is what is the views,
how many views did a piece
of content get
and things like that.
But we started looking
into it.
We'll have integration on
that coming up soon.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
that'll definitely
make your lives easier.
How you did it before with the
old APIs, you actually had to
download a zip file and
go through CSVs.
Now, you'll get all the
information correctly with
just the information you need.
KRISHNA MENON: So for us, our
users, since we're a creation
platform, YouTube is the most
popular destination site for
most of our users.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, that's
good to hear.
Yeah, that's good to hear.
Yeah, we definitely, when you
talk about the API, we put you
guys in the creation category,
because you create new content
that we add to YouTube.
Was there anything, I guess,
when you're working with the
APIs that you saw that
was counterintuitive?
KRISHNA MENON: No, no.
It was relatively
straightforward to use.
For what we're trying to do,
it was not a problem at all
adopting it.
So it was very straightforward.
JEREMY WALKER: And I know we
talked a little bit about
this, but are there features
you're hoping
to see in the future?
I know you guys mainly do
uploads, so your use case is
taken care of, but I always just
like to ask that question
in case you can think
of something.
KRISHNA MENON: Not currently.
Mostly, as you mentioned, it's
all about upload and
publishing.
And for that, we're
pretty good.
Once we get the analytics,
that'll be the
last missing piece.
I think at some point, if you
started doing where we're
taking input from YouTube, then
there might be some other
requests coming up.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
Well, great.
MARK FLOISAND: That's actually
a good point, because I think
one of the things we've heard
from customers that have
published and then have got
volume and good SEO, inbound
traffic coming to a particular
site or particular file is
what they do if they want
to make changes to
it once it's live?
And so I think as we go deeper,
looking at how we can
tackle that problem for people
rather than editing or
republishing, wiping out their
traffic and starting again,
that's probably an interesting
area to explore over time.
MARK FLOISAND: And one more
thing I wanted to show you on
my screen here is that--
I wanted to show you what the
finished output looked like.
You saw the preview
on the screen.
So this is going to be
what the finished
output looks like.
And so this is something that
was created on WeVideo.
Let me just go to the beginning
of the file.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISHNA MENON: So this
was created using
our storyboard version.
It's the 1960s theme.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
KRISHNA MENON: So hopefully,
that gave you an insight into
what WeVideo does.
JEREMY WALKER: Well,
that's great.
Well, thanks for coming on.
For everyone out there, we have
an open question forum.
So go to that link.
It's right below in the
description if you want to ask
a question on Google
Moderator.
And we can answer that.
In the meantime, Jeff, we
always do Stack Overflow
question of the week.
So I'll hand it over to
Jeff to go over that.
JEFF POSNICK: Thanks
so much, Jeremy.
So a couple interesting
questions to choose from this
week, and I wanted to focus on
one of them asked by a Stack
Overflow user named Chris.
And this focuses on the
aforementioned YouTube
analytics API.
So Chris, to distill his
question into a sound bite,
was curious about how quota
worked in the analytics API.
Specifically, he went into some
real details about how
many types of various calls you
can make before running
into quota limits.
So my response--
to elaborate a little
bit on what I
posted on Stack Overflow--
is that, first of all, we're
not really giving specific,
hard numbers.
We're not saying this particular
type of YouTube
analytics call costs 10 quota
units in this type plus 15.
And you have 10,000 per day
or something like that.
We just need to maintain a
little bit of flexibility
there in terms of adjusting
quota costs in the future or
adjusting the daily limits
in the future.
And once we document this
specific quota costs for this
specific type of call, we really
lose that flexibility
in changing things.
So apologies right off the bat
that we're not completely
transparent about that.
But that being said, we do have
some general guidelines
and some things that we make
clear from the documentation.
Chris linked to the
documentation and I'll post a
link out to the specific part
that I'm talking about into
our Google+ page after the show
so folks can go and refer
back to it.
But basically, what we say in
the docs is that the relative
quota costs of analytics
API calls depends
mainly on two things.
First of all, it depends upon
whether you're using a
dimension of a video, which
tends to be a little bit more
expensive, or if you're using a
different report dimension,
which tends to be a little
bit cheaper.
And second, it depends upon
the number of metrics that
you're requesting.
So you can think of it as a
little bit of a matrix where
you have maybe a dimension of
some sort of time period and
only one metric.
And that's probably going to
be your cheapest call.
But then if you started saying,
I want a mention of a
video and I want three different
metrics returned in
that report, I don't want to
say it's going to be three
times more expensive or five
times more expensive.
But it's going to be
more expensive.
So that's the overall
guidelines.
And then it gets into the
question of what should you as
developers do to code
defensively and to deal with a
little bit of uncertainty about
what the actual quota
limits are?
How should you write code
in that kind of reality?
I think the most important thing
to keep in mind-- and
this applies also to the
data API, not just
the analytics API--
is that you really should
not be afraid of quotas.
Don't be afraid to make a lot
of requests against the API
and potentially bump into
any quota limits.
It's very tempting to try to
scale things down on your end
and to put in I want to sleep
for one minute in between I
every call I make.
But I wouldn't really
recommend that.
I'd recommend make as many
calls as you need to make
against the API and wait
until we start
returning back quota errors.
And at that point, you should
adjust your traffic pattern.
We're not punishing
you when you do
encounter a quota error.
We don't disable access to the
API or anything like that.
We're just saying, hey, you're
going to need to slow down the
rate at which you are
making calls.
So what we recommend in the docs
is doing as much traffic
is you need to make.
And then when you do get
a quota error, start an
exponential back off pattern
where you basically will wait
for a certain period of time in
between receiving a quota
error and then making
your next request.
If you do happen get another
quota error back when you make
your next request, then you
wait twice as long as you
previously did, and then try
again, and so on and so forth.
It might be reasonable to start
with waiting a minute
after you get back your first
quota error and then retrying
after a minute.
And then retrying after two
minutes and four minutes and
so on, up to someone limit.
Probably, if things don't work
after pausing for 16 minutes,
at that point, maybe you should
give up, because maybe
you've pushed--
I don't want say pushed
your luck too much.
But actually, I've been playing
around with the
analytics API a little bit and
playing with seeing how the
quota limits are returned
from the API.
And we actually do distinguish
between short term quota
limits and the daily limit
that you've run into.
So you will get a different
error back from the API if you
run into one of the
short term or more
recoverable quota errors.
And in that case, you should
do the exponential back
[? offs. ?]
And then there is a separate
error saying, hey, you've
reach your maximum number
of API calls that
you make per day.
If you get that error back,
then at that point, you do
need to give up.
But the bar for running into
that daily limit is really
rather high.
And it might be adjusted
even higher in
future if we need to.
So that's a general philosophy
to have.
Don't be afraid of
quota errors.
Make the requests you
need to make.
Obviously, don't make
extra requests.
Don't just throw traffic
and at the API
servers for no reason.
But if you do need to make
these requests, go
ahead and make them.
So I'll post some links to our
Google+ page plus YouTube Dev
and share those things I've been
talking about during the
show so people can refer
back to them later.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Yeah.
People always ask that
when I go to events.
What I do about the
quota stuff?
And like you said, we're not
there to penalize you.
Use as much as you need
and then do back off.
But with the new APIs, like you
pointed out, only request
the information you need in
parts, whether that's on the
data API or just the metrics
you need in analytics API.
Because if you don't need,
it's costing you.
And you don't want it to cost
you if you don't need it.
So that's always important.
Well, thanks for that.
So we actually only have
one question so far.
And it's for me.
JEFF POSNICK: Do you
want to answer your
own question, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
Is Google Developer
Relations hiring?
Yes, we are.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY WALKER: Go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
We have a bunch of open
positions, if you are
interested, as a developer--
not necessarily here in the
States, but anywhere.
Let us now.
Check out that page.
We're always interested.
And we have a shortage of
people, so you definitely
should that out.
But I wanted to thank you
guys for coming on.
It was great demo.
It's really interesting.
And it's neat to see
the new features.
And as I said, we're always
happy to have you guys on
because we've worked with
you for so long.
And we had you on at
Google I/O. So
thanks again for coming.
KRISHNA MENON: Thank you.
MARK FLOISAND: We really
appreciate it.
Thank you very much for
having us today.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, thanks everyone
for attending.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I think maybe a programming
note--
we're going to be off for
the next two weeks.
We're not going to be doing our
weekly Wednesday show due
to various holidays.
And I think our next is what?
January 9 maybe?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, it's later
in January, I know.
So that's probably right--
January 9.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So sorry, everybody I know.
You'll have to go back
and watch some.
Actually, you know what?
Maybe we'll post on our Google+
some of our older
episodes from the archive that
folks might find interesting
to watch during our hiatus.
MARK FLOISAND: A year-end
outtakes.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF POSNICK: Indeed.
Indeed, yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: Well, thanks
again for coming.
And Jeff, thanks for joining
us from New York.
MARK FLOISAND: Absolutely.
KRISHNA MENON: Thank you.